Many English names have nicknames, I figure,...
...or people usually shorten the name when calling a person.
Let's see if I can come up with good examples,...
...Bill and William, Rob and Robert, Sam and Samuel, and of course, Alex and Alexander.
Does your name have a particular meaning to it?
Who gave you that name?
I believe my grandfather named me Alex.
You know, Alexander is a common male first name,...
...and this English name is taken from the Latin "Alexander,"...
...which means, "a protector of man."
Yes, it's a warrior-like name.
I wish I had a very unique name like "Condoleezza Rice".
Do you know how she got her name?
Her mom fashioned the name from the Italian term "con dolcezza"...
...from a musical score that instructs the performer to play "with sweetness."
How nice!
Yeah, if you have a unique name like her,...
...it will make other people remember you better, I guess.
Don't get me wrong, but I always get confused with English names.
It's really hard to match a person with his or her name.
They are all common.
Some Korean people still visit a shaman or a fortune teller for a newborn baby's name,...
...because of a strong belief that the name could change one's life.